Hello, hello, BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us for our second episode!
It's happening, Moco-chan.
Is it happening?
It's happening!
Today!
Despite of a FUWAMOCO Morning, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, Monday.
FUWAMOCO is hosted by us, FUWAMOCO Mococo.
What did you say?
FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag, hashtag, FWMCMORNING.
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Now, now, now.
Now.
Ruffians!
You know it!
We can't be quiet about this anymore.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Thank you for 400,000 Ruffians!
400,000 Ruffians!
And you know what?
It's only been four days since we debuted.
Only four days.
That's... Can you believe it?
We never ever thought we'd be at such a momentous moment so soon.
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you!
Arisato!
I'm really really happy and so thankful for all your warm support and all the happy BAU BAUs!
Yeah, happy BAU BAUs.
Yeah.
As you can imagine, it hasn't been a perfectly easy road.
Yeah, folks, folks, folks.
We're not really expecting it to be bad.
But even so, it's a thousand percent worth it.
Two thousand.
A thousand for me, a thousand for you, right?
Two thousand, yeah.
We want to continue to have lots of special times for you, okay?
So we're gonna do our best.
Thank you so much, Ruffians.
Thank you!
You know with every step, we're getting a little bit closer to our goal of 1 million ruffians.
Little step every day.
Right, right.
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
Next, we wanted to introduce something that we're really excited about but maybe you kind of overlooked.
I...
Sighting Voice Pack!
Sighting Voice!
Along with the release of Abyn's debut merch, was also the release of our Sighting Voice Pack!
Yeah, we talked about it before, but did you forget?
Maybe.
There's so much stuff, it's okay if you forgot.
Actually, this time, we're technically the first hololive members to have the Sighting Voices released at the very start of their time at hololive, so it's truly a sighting voice.
Very, very sighting.
Yeah.
But we had a lot of fun recording them, both in English and Japanese.
Maybe too much fun.
For Ruffians that don't know what the voice pack is, what is it?
We recorded a saying something just for you.
Something very special.
But it's a secret.
Until you find out.
But what's special about this starting voice is that we have actually two starting voices because there's one in English and one in Japanese.
And there's lots of different types, you know.
There's the self-introduction, the morning good morning voice, and the good night voice.
What are your thoughts?
Tell us!
Were you able to get them?
Very cute!
Love it!
Thank you!
And the Japanese one was good too!
See, that's the thing, because there's both the English and the Japanese.
Enjoy both, right?
This is what Fuwawa was like in English.
This is what she's like in Japanese.
I don't know if there's much of a better thing than getting a bit of help from Moco-chan or myself, waking up in FUWAMOCO morning.
Because it's the morning voice too, right?
Shiori, you can have the bestest, bestest FUWAMOCO Morning that way.
Every day?
Every day, yeah.
Shiori, even on Tuesdays and Thursdays.
Can you give the Ruffians maybe a tiny sample of what a starting voice might be like?
Like, morning, morning voice.
Morning voice?
I just woke up an hour ago.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I just started on my own.
3, 2, 1!
You're gonna wake me up?
No!
That's not a very cute starting voice.
That's not what it's like, you know?
But that's your example?
Question mark, question mark, question mark.
Moco-chan, what's your example then?
It's very different from reality.
You'll have to find out.
3, 2... I gotta count down.
Okay, okay, count down, count down.
3, 2, 1, 1!
Excuse me.
It's time to wake up now.
It's very different from reality too.
Please wake up now.
It's time to wake up now.
You'll have to find out what reality is actually like by checking out the starting voices.
Let us know more about your thoughts with the hashtag FUWAMOCO.
We'll be looking.
Let us know how you enjoy them too.
Thank you!
Don't say thank you there.
Thank you.
Well, unfortunately, we have a continuation of this corner.
Didn't intend to continue, but here we are.
It happened.
It happened again.
There's been a misunderstanding.
There has been.
Well, you know what?
And yesterday's typing of the dead overkill stream, Moco-chan might have added a word that took everyone by surprise for that.
And as Moco-chan's older sister, I would like to apologize very very deeply.
Moco-chan?
What?
What are you gonna say?
I'm sorry that I shocked you.
Moco-chan, you're not gonna say things like that again, right?
I didn't say anything.
You might have heard something else, but it wasn't what you thought, okay?
I'm an innocent puppy.
Okay?
Is that enough of an apology?
Ruffians, I don't know.
I'm innocent!
Forgive me!
You have to apologize straight, Moco-chan.
I'm sorry.
Kono tabi wa taihen moushiwaki gozaimasen deshita.
You apologized too, Moco-chan.
I apologized!
I don't know if it's enough.
Mococo did nothing wrong!
I did nothing wrong.
Are you sure that's an apology?
Yes.
Well, there's been another misunderstanding.
Maybe it's a happiness one?
Well, maybe.
You saw on Twitter, but all of hololive was interviewed by Crunchyroll.
It sounds delicious.
Did you check some of them out?
Ours was actually released yesterday.
We talked a lot about what it was like becoming a member of hololive.
Also about our favorite anime too.
We were supposed to choose only our top 10 anime, but in the end, we only got to 11.
Yeah.
I feel like there's a lot more.
There is a lot more.
No, like, I feel like I had 50.
Why?
I was like, oh, this one wasn't included.
That one wasn't included.
Like, ah, I forgot something.
Yeah, like, ah.
But, uh,
Can you imagine what it was like, the process between the two of us to be able to decide?
It was a very long process.
A bit of a battle.
Weighing, you know, this and that, this and that.
Very important.
But there's been a misunderstanding.
Again.
Some of the pictures in the article maybe were a bit confusing.
We would like to specify.
Yes, specify.
Kemono Friends!
Kemono Friends 1.
We did not watch 2.
No.
There's a reason.
For Genshiken, we might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might, might,
You understand?
Original.
We want you to understand.
Kujian's OVA.
It's so good.
That's Kujian's OVA.
But it's inside of Genshiken.
True, true, true.
You get it?
Understand?
Understood?
Understandable?
Good?
We hope you enjoyed the long form interview.
If you haven't checked it out, please check it out.
Maybe was there anything else that stood out or surprised you?
There was also a special voice that we recorded just for it.
So please go check it out, okay?
There's a Kemono Friends 2?
No there isn't.
I don't know what to read.
The biggest misunderstanding of all.
I think the Ruffians know.
You know, during a Q&A stream,
Got a very good question about what some of our favorite Japanese words are, you know?
It's a good question.
But, unfortunately there was a bit of confusion with my answer.
It was kind of really, really, really embarrassing to say much more and explain more, but you know there's a good reason, there's a good reason.
So, in English, you know, there's... Ruffians, what?
But, in English!
But, but Fuwawa explain!
There's no specific word for this, you know, because you don't need a word like that.
It's not necessary.
But, you know, in Japan, like, it was like a way to woo and confess a girl that you liked and get married.
You know, it's interesting, like, culturally.
But, but, you know, if you think about it,
But then, I have a bit of a story.
One day... That's so bad!
I was watching Japanese TV!
I was watching Japanese TV, and a TV crew was interviewing elderly couples, and you know, asking them how they met.
And then there was this one grandpa that was like,
Yobai.
And he was like... And then the grandma started to get so mad at him!
Yeah, they had a very interesting relationship dynamic.
She was very, very angry.
I was really shocked, you know?
I felt like... Yobai is very, very, very real now.
Do you understand now?
Do you understand?
Maybe, do you feel like it's a really interesting Japanese word too?
Is it your favorite now too?
I like homorebi.
Homorebi's good too, but it doesn't have the impact.
Understand now, yes?
Yes.
Mazui.
Really?
It's interesting from a cultural standpoint.
You like it too?
It's your favorite too!
My sister is embarrassing.
I wasn't the one that said the other thing, Moco-chan.
What did I say?
You apologized, but now you don't even remember.
Was that really an apology?
I'm innocent!
Okay, well it seems like the ruffians understand, so... Misunderstanding?
No more.
Cleared!
We have a confession.
Right, Moco-chan?
You are something that you confess.
And then I'll just nod.
So, there is something that I wanted to say.
During our Q&A stream the other day, I think there was a question about if there's any senpai in particular that we look up to.
And we answered that we love all senpai.
Because they all have their own special traits.
And it makes them unique and strong.
And that's true, yeah.
And we really admire all of them.
But we do have senpai we admire the most.
But... To tell the truth,
We don't really want to say names outright because we don't want to put pressure on them, you know?
Yeah, no pressure.
They're very, very busy.
Yeah, we wouldn't want to do that straight from the start to them, you know?
Do you understand?
BAU!
You understand!
But yeah, we saw something, you know, and in our hearts we're like, oh, that's not how we feel at all.
There's been a misunderstanding.
Yeah.
Yeah, but this is not the misunderstanding corner.
This is the confession corner.
Yeah.
So, today, we wanted to talk about one senpai in particular that we both admire.
I mentioned it before, but I was actually so nervous then!
I felt like I was gonna forget what I was saying and the titles of songs that I've listened to over and over and over, because I was too shaky.
So, I couldn't say anything.
I couldn't say what I wanted to say, but now I feel the same, so...
But I wanted to say... I don't know if it's ready!
Okay, I'm going to say it with a clear consciousness.
Consciousness?
Yeah.
Okay.
I really admire Fuka-senpai.
Moco-chan drew a special drawing too.
I really admire all her charisma, energy, her voice, her humor, and especially I really really love her music.
Especially her originals, but also her covers too.
I tried to say it, but my favorite song is definitely Ever Blue, because whenever it comes on I always have to stop in my tracks and be like, wait!
It's my song!
It's not your song!
It's not my song!
But it's like, you know, it's my song.
You know?
And it's embarrassing, but I actually can't watch Psychotic Poker without crying, so I don't attempt to watch it anymore.
It makes Moco-chan cry.
Good tears, not sad tears.
Yeah, but it makes me cry.
And my favorite cover of hers is Kick Back.
And whenever I hear regular Kick Back, I have to stop listening to it and go listen to Pokka's Kick Back.
Because she made it her own song with the high harmony, and I can't listen to it without the high harmony.
Yeah, we really admire Poko-senpai's drive.
No, I'm embarrassed!
But you know, Poko-senpai, I'm sure you feel this way too, but she's so funny and she's made us laugh a lot too.
Even though her mouse was broken.
Yeah, it was broken.
We forget Poko-senpai.
She wouldn't ever say anything that's not true.
That's all.
Did I manage to say this without being all over the place?
No.
Confession over.
Over.
Well next, we're gonna go to our regular question.
We have our Doggie of the Day!
De-den!
Here's the Doggie of the Day, BAU BAU BAU BAU!
His name is Paco, and he's the Barking Warrior.
It's like, FUWAMOCO Paco.
FUWAMOCO Paco!
Look at his little eyes, they have like a soft glint of
What a heroic face.
Yeah, very brave.
I can see it right there.
He kind of looks like a movie star.
A very unique face.
Yeah, sort of like a... Like somebody in Star Wars.
Like Han Solo.
Yeah.
I wonder what... Very, very royal feeling.
What does his bike sound like?
I think it's kind of like... I think he's like a...
I would give Paco the reading that you'll probably never ever lose him in a doggy pack.
He's a very unique and lovely boy.
Make sure you protect your smile, okay?
Because it's really really bright.
Are we sure that nose is real and not fake?
It looks like one on a teddy bear.
Thank you for the Doggie of the Day!
Next corner is... Today, I went on a walk.
Today's walk is this!
It's so beautiful.
Nice nature path.
Yeah, yeah.
Is it the morning or the daytime?
It looks like morning!
You know, I think it'd be very, very nice all day, right?
Yeah.
Except, I guess, maybe for night.
But that's not daytime.
That's too scary.
It looks like ghosts could come out.
Not in the daytime.
Only nighttime.
It also kind of reminds me of the Northwest Passage a little bit.
It makes me feel a bit nostalgic too, right?
The air is probably really nice and fresh and crisp.
There's probably a lot of bugs around.
Is that a good thing or a bad thing?
It's neutral.
Make sure to dress appropriately when going out on the rough trails like this, right?
And let your loved ones know beforehand too.
Make sure you're looking where you step, okay?
Yeah, not to fall on them.
No tumble.
Thank you!
Bye bye!
And for our Question of the Day... De-den!
Do you have to remove your human ears when you go to bed?
Also, I thought I lost my smile, but you were protecting it all along.
Thank you!
We promise to protect it forever and ever.
Moco-chan, you're just gonna wink there?
Yeah, I'm just gonna stand here and wink.
But to the question.
Removing our human ears when we go to bed?
We don't!
No.
Why do you think they're removable?
They're decoration, but they're there.
They don't come off.
They are handy, you know?
They do have purposes and uses other than just appearance.
But it is like your ears, where they just sit there.
You know, there's like, these things that are like, they're self-healing eye masks.
And you can put them on your face when you go to bed.
And then you have to, you can't put them on the doggy ears.
You have to put them on the...
It makes it really easy and nice to fall asleep.
It smells really good too!
Bugging you how?
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU
Thank you for the question!
BAU BAU!
And our next theme is... De-den!
Moco-chan, are you going to say today?
Today!
Today we play Love for the Tube with all of Abyss!
I missed game collab altogether.
You haven't forgot, right?
You haven't, right?
Even though I'm kind of tired of the zombies.
Just a bit.
It's okay because I'm really looking forward to...
Protecting Biboo and Shiori and Arisa, so... And the Ruffians, you're gonna help us too, right?
Right!
I don't think we're gonna be the best zombie fighters right off the bat here, but... We'll do our best, so... But actually... We'll let you know a special secret, because you're here with us right now.
A secret for the Ruffians that are here right now.
There's a good, good reason to wake up early, right?
Today, at the very end,
There's going to be a special announcement from all of Abyss!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
You'll absolutely want to be there, so don't miss it, okay?
You heard that right.
Special announcement.
Yes.
Thank you!
That's great!
Let's have a quick last peek at our schedule.
Ice Catcher!
Tomorrow is going to be our first FUWAMOCO Rocket Word Party!
It's our first Karaoke.
We actually got a question, right Moco-chan?
Yes, we got a question about if it will be archived or not.
For our karaoke, it'll almost always be archived.
Unless something unexpected and rough happens to it.
If it's gonna be an archive, we'll always let you know in the title if it's gonna be like that.
It'll say in the title, unarchived.
Don't worry, don't worry.
You will know.
And there's also still the question, question, question mic.
We've almost gotten to the week, but we still don't know what it is.
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special viewers today.
XZY.
BAU BAU!
Lua.
Basha.
BAU BAU!
Gucci.
400,000!
BAU BAU!